تحدث الزلازل في كثير من الأحيان في بعض الأحيان
كل 20 دقيقة وأحيانًا كل ثماني
دقائق كلما حدث زلزال
أتحرك وفقًا لشدة الأرض
هي مصممة الرقصات للقطعة وأنا
فقط أفسر عايدة أنها
أعطتني هذه القصة العظيمة التي أصبحت
ممكنة بواسطة IBM  التخطيط
لبرنامج تحليلات للتنبؤ القوي المبسط ،
اسمي قمر ريفاس
وأنا فنان سايبورغ لدي هذه
الغرسات في
قدمي المتصلة بجميع أحجام تطبيقاتي وفي كل مرة
يحدث فيها زلزال أشعر
بالاهتزاز داخل جسدي.
نسمي هذه المعنى الزلزالي وهو
الشعور بالنشاط الزلزالي
للكوكب في الوقت الفعلي لدينا
الإحساس الزلزالي منذ عام 2013 لذلك هناك
زلزال في إندونيسيا أو اليونان أو
في اليابان ومن ثم يشعر به جهاز قياس الزلازل
وتنتقل هذه البيانات عبر الإنترنت  وبعد
ذلك عندما أشعر بالاهتزاز داخل أجهزة الخادم
، واعتمادًا
على شدة الزلزال ، يكون
المجال الاهتزازي
كنت أقوم بدراسة فن الرقص أو أقل قوة ،
فهناك راقص لا يمكنك إنشاء
الحركة ولكن يمكنك أيضًا العثور على
الحركة وأنا أعلم أنه إذا وحدت نفسي ،
يمكن أن تستكشف التكنولوجيا الحركة
بطريقة أعمق بالنسبة لي عندما
أؤديها قليلاً  هذه الأرض
الحية لدرجة أنها ليست صخرة ثابتة
إنها كائن حي ،
أمنيتي هي خلق التعاطف تجاه
الأرض والأنواع الأخرى لديّ
أداء يُدعى انتظار
الزلازل وهو عبارة
عن قطعة أداء تدوم في الوقت الحقيقي بالنسبة لي
مثل التمثال الحي ، فأنا أقف بلا
حراك وكلما حدث زلزال في
أي مكان أتحرك وفقًا
لشدة الزلزال ، لذا إذا لم يكن
هناك زلزال في الأداء
فلن يكون هناك رقص ، فهو يشبه إلى
حد ما دويتو بين الأرض من أجل
أنا كما لو كنت تعلم أن لدي هذا
الارتباط بالحركة
الطبيعية للأرض أشعر وكأنني أملك إيقاعًا جديدًا
مثل نبضات قلبي ومن ثم
الأرض سيكون لدينا أي إيقاع محدد في المناطق  ID
جسدي
[موسيقى]
أنت